字幕提供
哈囉大家好
歡迎來到AI視覺實驗室
大家最近在使用Groke
Imagine的時候有沒有發現
你花很多時間去打指令
結果到最後呢
按送出的時候
付費頁面就跳出來了
難道現在已經沒有免費的影片生成工具了嗎
今天這集影片我們就要聊聊被大家常常忘記的AI影片生成工具Meta AI
Meta AI剛出來的時候也跟TrackGPT一樣不能生成圖片或是影片
只能單純的問問題
不過現在呢它已經加上影片生成的功能
而且最近也加上了很多新的功能
它是想要成為AI生成影片的短影音平台
因此它的默認是深層9比16的影片
那今天我們就要教你如何破解它的限制
利用它的局部編輯與自定義動畫做出零成本
無符隨印又好用的影片
那Meta AI的註冊或登入很簡單
它這邊只能使用臉書或是IG
進來之後你會發現它其實長得跟Gemini、ChairGPT甚至是Groke都很像
中間是詢問的對話框
左邊是功能
因為不知道Meta什麼時候會把免費的功能關掉所以我建議大家看完趕快去試試看剛剛有提到如果我們直接生成影片會變成9比16的比例
所以我們要先進到Create
手動選取16比9
在這邊輸入你的指令
你就會得到四張高品質橫平的圖片
選好你最滿意的,我們再去按Animate
就可以得到橫屏的影片素材
好,生成好橫的影片之後呢,我們來看一下它右邊有的功能
第一個,它可以下載
它可以分享
它可以更改圖片指令
下面這邊,如果同學不喜歡
直接生成影片
這邊你也可以打上你的影片生成運鏡指令
這邊還可以加上音樂
使用的音樂就是Meta裡面的音樂資料庫
到時候如果你發布到Meta AI的影片平台
就會附上音樂
接下來我們也可以看到這邊有Extend延伸功能
所以同學
我們在Meta AI生成的影片也跟之前的Grog一樣
不會再被局限於短短的5-6秒
最下面這邊有一個叫做Restyle
你可以更改你生成好的影片的風格
接下來我們要解釋Vibes還還有它的基本用法Vibes是Meta於2025年9月正式發表的一個功能
其實就是Meta推出的AI短影音創作與分享平台
它核心的概念是打造一個由AI驅動的短片社群
它的基本功能有AI影片創作
用戶不需要具備專業的剪輯技術
只需要透過Meta AI的應用程式提供指令
即可快速生成端影片
另外還可以用混搭與編輯
用戶可以針對現有的VIBE進行混搭
例如圖像或影片加上對嘴、旁白、動畫
VIBE在Meta AI裡面擁有獨立的Feed
也就是我們的動態牆讓用戶瀏覽、分享
由AI生成的純虛擬內容
那我們今天Focus的內容
並不是教大家如何用VibesPO出你的AI社群短片
而是要告訴大家
如果我們對提示詞的運用並不是很熟悉
或是明明很會使用提示詞
就是突然沒有靈感
Meta AI的Vibes區塊其實就是你的靈感來源
那點開任何影片呢
你都可以直接在左邊看到它的 prompt
看到喜歡的你就可以直接存下來
之後呢就可以直接在你自己的創作當中去修改運用
如果看到不熟悉的語言呢也不用擔心
我們都直接貼回給Meta AI請他幫我們翻譯就好
這樣我們就可以知道裡面要修改的內容要修改的關鍵字有哪些在影片工作流程當中隨機性是我們就可以知道裡面要修改的內容、要修改的關鍵字有哪些在影片工作流程當中,隨機性是我們最大的敵人
那Meta AI Canvas Edit其實算是一個蠻精準的控制工具
這邊我們選中自己生成好的圖片
如果覺得細節需要微調,我們直接點開圖片
會在右邊發現Edit Image
你就可以直接在這邊去描述你要的變化
最後呢我們來看到Custom Animate
前面我們在介紹影片生成的時候
我們是直接點Animate
讓他幫我們進行圖身影的動態
我們之前幾部影片也都有教大家運鏡指令
如果呢我們在這邊輸入具體的動作指令
例如Slow Cinematic Zoom In
Zoom in
緩慢的電影風格變焦
這就可以讓你的畫面具備
專業的鏡頭美學
一樣你自己拍的照片
或是從其他地方生成的圖片
你也可以上傳到Meta AI進行Animate
所以到目前為止呢
這也是一個蠻強大的免費AI影片生成工具
雖然Groke的免費影片圖片生成功能取消了
可是我們還有Meta AI
同學趁他還沒開始收費之前趕快去試試看吧
如果你喜歡這類的AI影片教學小技巧
請訂閱、按讚並分享我的頻道
這裡是AI視覺實驗室
我們下期見,掰掰!